[Music]  I'm just as excited as the fans I I'm a  fan of these movies Tom Holland is  opening up about the latest installment  of spider-man finally here we go good  evening here Oh  each II spoke with the 21 year old actor  who plays Peter Parker in the new film  spider-man homecoming at a special  screening on Monday where he opened up  about meeting to former Spider Men Tobey  Maguire and Andrew Garfield  Andrew was so lovely we had a really  good chat together I met Toby very  briefly but they're both nice guys -  nice clothes Tom also explained his  reason for borrowing co-stars and daya's  leather jacket for an event recently  which the internet went wild over then  there is the wallet at serving looks  she's the one to go for the test I ran  out of new clothes I was like yo mate  can you help me out I don't have any  clothes to wear for this event and she  was like oh I have this jacket Joanna  will borrow it and I tried it on I still  have it  [Music]  you